i wasn't a boy band though
you guys didn't know this is after the
gang it would have to be and then and
then chill didn't you go on like go for
is it america's got talent or something
oh no the other one what gang you're
going to be in
you can't go from my imagination
[Laughter]
[Music]
got these new sunglasses are they new
though are those standard ray-bans no
well well they're new to me i bought
them okay it's not like they're like i
got the hot new no i only get ray-bans
and i have um
uh five pairs and i didn't bring a uh a
pair when i went to disneyland ooh do
you think that stops me no no apparently
what do you mean sunglasses that's all
they're all made by the same company and
like you know by the way how how long
have i seen you today so far maybe 15
minutes maybe you've said something as a
racket twice
rackets and that's true racket's an
older term no i i [ __ ] you
i'm with you i get the reference i'm not
racist
ccr i was telling him i have to go to
canada and you gotta get the pcr test to
go to canada that [ __ ] is a racket that
is a that's a hustle okay
i'm telling you these kids call them
expensive sunglasses also
okay so they're all being made
factory and they're like the ones you
get at yeah 7-eleven the same ones
ray-ban selling for three okay but
they're but these don't break and the
ones that 7-eleven do
and those are polarized ones 7-11 aren't
these are good good sunglasses and by
the way what do you think is what do you
think is an expensive
an expensive pair of sunglasses what
would you say maybe like 850 it is an
expensive pair of sunglasses 850. right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
i'd say like 200 300 i would say
230 is like okay that's now you talking
about with the uh but the lenses that
are like you know i don't know but this
is these are like 120. so like i mean
that's
money but it's like
oh my god it's a couple shirts
you know what he when you know when he
first when he first started really
blowing up yeah he would he would just
text me things like
god i make so much money
and i heard it and i heard his voice
like as i read it i heard this voice and
i was just like uh but you can only send
it to your friends you know people would
be appalled this stuff
oh forgot chris brian like when i got my
friend just sent a picture of me sipping
on coffee yeah thanks comedy you know
just like it's just stupid
the first one that we would do was
thanks life yeah we'd have like whatever
whatever [ __ ] we bought and we'd be like
thanks life
[Music]
yeah i saved that for the friends yeah
yeah how good did it feel i i would say
i've been around you for a while
the happiest i've seen you was this past
weekend in oxnard yeah i yeah it was it
was really nice um
[Music]
i do you know it started crying again i
i feel that all the time it's like i
never felt emotionally open ever ever
ever ever and i feel that way about you
too yeah i know you know what when i was
when i was when i was
when i remember when i was 16 i got my
[ __ ] heart broken and that was when i
found out about tupac's music and i was
like it's never going to be the same
[ __ ] nobody's breaking my heart
oh you got you we went thug life yep i
did oh from from 16 year old you're
saying yeah
ever since then i just i've been closed
the [ __ ] off turned into bane yeah from
one girl breaking your heart now and um
and so uh and then i i [ __ ] uh
uh now i'm just every everything i have
my son and all this [ __ ]
bro i can't i can't you start talking
about oh and then i think about my kid i
think about the people that game over my
friends and i'm just it's it i i do i
get [ __ ] i just get emotional bro
yeah i'm completely open my therapist
was like oh with your kid you're you're
[ __ ] you can't live like that anymore
and i'm like i know um so now
that's it
that's it i'm an emotional guy no no no
just crying over that's it dude i'll cry
at a hang
we'll chill and i'll be crying and you
know what dude i won't break eye contact
with you oh no you should cry
i'll cry in your eyes
yeah bro well you know i i have this
thing where like if i go to a movie with
a friend and i get emotional yeah and
they don't get emotional yep we're done
wow that's
i really like that rule yeah i like that
rule because if you're crying during
[ __ ] fast and furious nine yeah you
don't want to be that guy's friend there
could be a moment though no i know and
that's
no you know what it was i'll tell you i
had this friend that i don't hang out
with anymore we saw the remake of karate
kid with jackie chan and there's a
moment jackie chan is having where his
family died
wow i'm already out just like
okay first of all you need to watch it
before you like people
you know what dude you don't yes you do
all right all right the remake of karate
kid with jackie chan yes jackie chan had
a beautiful moment about his family all
right i'm telling you right now oh and i
was with my sons in it and my friend was
like what
the way he was acting i was like i'm
done with you okay because you don't
understand the emotional turmoil that is
going on in this scene and that was it
and that was it that was it you never
talked to him again pretty much
that's a pretty hard chord yeah hey it
is what it is
this person is yeah okay it wasn't just
that it was the conversation we were
having about it yeah as if he didn't
understand anything i was like oh you're
just not emotionally connected to
anything so i can't be i had two friends
i had one friend
uh this was years ago but i had so there
were two friends and and the three of us
would hang out a lot and so one guy had
a um a job at a restaurant and in the
beginning of the re in the beginning of
the uh time he was working there he
borrowed a pen from a guy that worked it
was like a busboy at the restaurant and
he said can i um borrow a pen and i said
it's my only pen don't don't lose it and
he lost it
okay worked at the restaurant for a few
years when it was his last day at the
restaurant he said hey man i lost your
pen that one day and i wanted to give
you a pen i'm leaving and he told this
to our other friend and our other friend
thought it's just he said it's just a
[ __ ] pen you [ __ ] yeah you know what
i mean yeah and and i but i was like the
difference you know because i was in the
middle there and i was like i get it but
i'm not going to cry but my buddy was
like crying about his emotional
experience about working at this
restaurant i just think it's i think you
got to be in the middle
you don't you're doing it being in the
middle is good yeah yeah yeah i'm being
in the middle of this i'm more with you
i'll cry [ __ ] i almost cried during
dexter last night you feel me like if
you saw the final they'll find out whoa
whoa i'm on season six [ __ ] me dude it's
been sick it's terrible i've never seen
it terrible i'm one through i'm one
through six i just finished six this new
season
yeah
i agree but but you're not going to ruin
it yeah the new i'm just going to say
how good or bad it was
one through whatever the john lithgow
season was three the original writer and
then she went on to do the twilight she
went cool story that's why right right
then it got actually bad yes yes the one
with julius styles was terrible oh i
disagree oh dude i'm out dude i'll see
you guys later man gotta go
wait hold on
no i'm gonna cry
no but this uh this this new season they
heard it's good they they ended the
series the way they should have the new
series you getting close yeah you're
getting close dude i'm just gonna say it
was good yeah me too it was watchable no
no but but we can't take away
from what we know about the bad stuff
this is just a makeup yeah trying to
make it yeah yeah you don't invest in
the characters the season can suck and i
still [ __ ] with it like the writing can
be bad but once you're into the
character for how
you're a guy who will like stop on
season 18. they're like all right you
know what no no i've already stopped so
when it just when when rick was off the
show oh i was way stopped before that
yeah but i shouldn't
when he wrote the show i was like
ooh i should have been with him he knew
like he knew he knew like you know year
three of his contract he was like i
gotta get out of this yeah the thing
that [ __ ] me is i talked about dexter
on pods or whatever now i was at
starbucks the guy go i'll see
i haven't seen it dude yeah he's like
dude you get do you get the part where
no the dexter and sister are [ __ ] no
no no i haven't dude yeah yeah yeah and
you [ __ ] me yeah yeah yeah hey hey
spoiler alert i don't think after 10
years [ __ ] you it's it you don't get to
be like yeah don't tell me no you know
what dude you're sick and i don't tell
me about the ending of six years i don't
say that i've always been that guy eric
is right the same eric is right he's
also a season this old though like 10
years yeah you want us to be like no
spoilers well you can't be like
dude you get to the point where dexter
is [ __ ] his sister like yeah no
you need to catch they [ __ ] yeah they
[ __ ] i don't think they did they hooked
up i guess they had no no he was [ __ ]
around yeah he was messing with it that
doesn't happen you guys are lying i'm
not lying but you don't know if we are i
looked it up i look good hey everybody
if you see brandon
spoil it he's like i want to make sure
he spoiled it he spoiled it
everybody just walk up to him and tell
him like lies about the show yeah yeah
i'll take that yeah
what's this that's sad
oh man this is our first uh king or
debate club oh damn familiar face
what's up king of the sting it's your
boy
i got a debate for you probably
singer mainly this question is foreign
who do you think is going to win this
foot race
me or brenda
get back at me what is she being done is
that hello cool jay
that was sexy why is she being this is
that is that montel jordan sexy he gets
a little fair he's like yo
yo this guy's guy
[ __ ]
3 000 views all of a sudden he's acting
like he's [ __ ] yo what's up i'm
triple platinum
yo man don't get a lot of time be doing
this
[Laughter]
by the way you can't act cooler than the
guy on your shirt yeah that's the rule
maybe he's channeling his enemies
all right so the question is so
chappelle
i'm finally kid he thinks no not even he
thinks in a sprint in a 100 meter sprint
he can beat me in a race but
that's
well the
to me
i don't really know his athletic ability
but he's a cheerleader but apparently he
i guess he used to race
guys in high school but i don't know it
seems like you were
you seem very confident about this
i was but then you know chappelle he's
like the nice guy he's too nice you know
when you're too nice think somebody's
gay but yeah
yeah yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah so friendly but yeah what do you
want from me yeah
you know he's a confident dude but he's
never he's never bragging with this he's
like all i'll be that's him my band's on
that's him yeah but that's when he was
11.
he's way that's crazy yeah he ate that
guy yeah yeah he looks like 100
the only thing that's alarming is how
confident he is and beating me yeah i
was like oh [ __ ] this one
[Music]
do you believe whoa
dude
that is crazy yeah i mean he's off the
kid
i think we're doing it tomorrow oh then
the results will be out by the time this
airs yeah so that's exciting yeah i'm
not like super confident now okay
have i run the 40 for the nfl yeah how
have i did i did i spend years with
technique to run right yeah yeah well
that's the thing it's like you were a
professional athlete so i would i would
go with you but
back
yeah a while ago yeah he's black oh he's
black
yeah yeah yeah fat no black guys have
twitch muscles eric show us
that's only exactly half my drama
your white
[Laughter]
let's take a little break from chatting
with the squad because it is time for
ufc 270 the heavyweight title fight
between the undefeated cyril gone the
knockout artist francis ingano for these
guys it could take just one punch you
know this same goes for you at
draftkings sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the ufc new
customers can bet just one dollar and
win a hundred in free bets if either
fighter lands a punch which they well
otherwise can be a terrible fight
rather bet this weekend's football games
cool man the nfl playoffs is popping
draftkings also has a special offer for
those looking to get in on the gridiron
action
new customers can get 56 to one odds on
any playoff team better my rams beat the
chiefs bet just five dollars and get 280
in free bets if your team wins download
the draftkings sportsbook app now use
promo code kats throw down just one
dollar on the ufc 270 main event and win
100 in free bets if gone or ngano land a
punch all right that's code kats this
saturday at draftkings sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
ufc must be 21 or older new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only minimum 5 deposit one
one dollar wager required one per
customer restrictions fly see
draftkings.com sportsbook for details
gambling problem call 100 gambler the
new year is here and there's no better
way to kick off 2022
than by making sure you're feeling your
best man maybe your goal is to get in
shape maybe you're on this diet but you
know what your diet's not hitting
everything you need that liquid iv
hitter man all you do is put it in 16
ounces of water it hydrates faster more
efficiently than water alone all right
and my favorite flavor is watermelon for
your boy one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounce of water again hydrates faster
than water alone maybe you're getting
ready for the thick mudder january 29th
at 10 a.m the 15k with your thick friend
here and you're working hard you're
losing nutrients you're losing water
that's where liquid iv got you covered
man all right we got you guys covered
we're talking about one stick it
hydrates way faster than water so grab
liquid iv in bulk nationwide at costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com use the code kats at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you use promo code cats at
liquidity.com
experience better hydration today at
liquid iv.com promo code k-a-t-s do you
guys have a wager in this at all maybe
someone wears like a hay no thousand
thousand thousand look at our resident
gambling addict right here no no why
don't you look like a gambler
[ __ ] is always talking about
what he's wagering on man i need some
action no yeah no and again this is what
alarms me as chappelle's like i bet you
a thousand dollars
which
okay you know it's like [ __ ] chappelle
or maybe maybe he has some
[ __ ] freak ability we don't know
about yeah but also he's all in your
head
oh no i'm not don't get twisted i'm not
worried i'm just saying like
i think what's what's alarming is how
confident he is where i'm either gonna
get blown out of the [ __ ] water yeah
yeah yeah yeah so [ __ ]
he has no idea what he's signing up yeah
yeah i got it when i first met him he
goes
we're you know we're talking he's like
yeah man and he's like playing the fl
right i'm like i had a [ __ ] cup of
tea with the buffalo bills man i didn't
play yeah he goes yeah i ran a 4-3
in in the 40. which if anybody that
knows 40's that's unheard of he did that
that's what he said yeah he was around
43 and i go and we didn't know each
other no he didn't he's there in fourth
day
kill running four three yeah goes oh
[ __ ] yeah i didn't run a four three i'm
like i'm telling you dude yeah yeah
so he's delusional then
i don't know also
he's way bigger than he was yeah
he's he's black he's got fast twitch
muscles aren't choices you're bigger
than you were too though you got them
thighs boys yeah
but
you guys are both you know what honestly
don't do that
you're both 40 it's like chill you know
no he's younger you're 35 you're looking
trim yeah yeah you are yeah yeah but
he's starting from nothing in two weeks
oh wow i'm lightheaded that's crazy bro
i'm in my head right now you gotta eat
carbs you're lightheaded
you [ __ ]
what send that to your girls yeah but
you're gonna pass out you're gonna pass
out from doing that
dude you gotta eat carbs no you don't
not like a big cat at the zoo i just see
red meat baby all right well you're very
good you're like a big guy
all right if they don't give it to the
tigers at the zoo i don't want it okay
eric okay chris what do you think
let's put it down
i have no idea this is like he's been
training i feel like you've been
training really hard i think i think i
think brennan is going to win i got i'm
you know what just to be contrary
about i'm going with chappelle because
he's brian chappelle too and i looked at
brian gill brian why do you have him
like you've seen me run yeah i've seen
what i've done and and brian was like
well you know i went he's blagios yes
i just know you've been training hard
and i i don't think he has been training
hard he can still backflip though so we
just talking about a hundred meter dash
bro yeah
yeah how many meters are you gonna tape
it right oh it's just me all over the
world we're taping everything make sure
you have chariots of fire playing
they're doing it on the today show huh
they're doing it on the today show
on the today show no kelly ripley's
gonna go like this
with a gun and shoot chappelle by
mistake and it's gonna be a race thing
and then it's [ __ ] your world and then
the whole show yeah um
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
this guy's got another debate club
that's what is that homeboy looks like
is that like a tall christian it looks
like it looks like dirt chicken but a
little bit like christian in georgia
it missed theo just slanging words that
christian
what up eric stevie the actual host
brendan theo when he feels like being
there this is jens from sunny golden
colorado at the colorado school of mines
scientists smart dudes out here yes some
smart people actually do listen to the
podcast anyways
for you i was just wondering say you're
a steep little guy likes db i guess this
question really doesn't apply to brendan
but say you're a little guy like stevie
you're at a bar somebody's wanted to
start to throw hands
who do you want at your side that
spaghetti arms delia or that rinky dinky
kid cowan
let me know oh good question at a bar at
a bar bar fight
and you're you're stevie you know like
i'm i'm going to protect you like you're
my hot girl with big tits thank you yep
but that you're he's saying he's saying
let's say steve
i don't need help yeah of course but if
i i know i'm just all right okay well
what happens with your belt
no anyways but it's stevie's at a bar
yeah some dudes are about one dude's
about to [ __ ] him up
he's saying who do you want as like
brian or me yes gotcha bro you can't
answer that right now but what what do
you think
you taking brian
i've actually seen brian
at the boxing rink you know
now now but chris did you know when
chris he gets into something he's
[ __ ] addicted yeah yeah he did
remember that we have a purple belt yeah
that's higher than brian in japanese but
i was blue and brazilian yeah okay but
also do you have to know again brian is
uh
a fly he's very lightning he's so light
yeah i will say this about brian though
i we were out uh somewhere in the valley
this is when i first moved to l.a and
he's like let's get a drink you want me
to meet him
in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and
we're there and we're having some drinks
and hell's angels are there and one of
the hell's angels recognized me and and
you know
i guess there's a thing with like they
have a enforcer and they like to like
test themselves and they're like keep
looking i'm like oh [ __ ] i've
had it happen before
i'm not calling out hell's angels at all
yeah actually yeah we all love you i was
i was i was i was just like oh no dude
he's like well i'm like dude they're
like they're tough guys get because at
the time i was like in the ufc right
like top ten yeah and i was like dude
they're going to want to do this
and i thought calm like oh my god what
are we going to do but he was like all
right dude here's the plan like i was
like no we're not going to fight him
dude but that's why he was down but
that's why he's going to get his [ __ ]
ass kicked brian was but he was down
though like right he has some dog in him
here's my thoughts there he is right
there that's after we fought the hell's
aim
he knocked his teeth out but here's my
thoughts between brian and chris
when it that's about to happen
who
would
talk talk them down oh a hundred chris
yeah brian would make it worse yeah he
would make it
you know what my boy will do i'm like
whoa whoa whoa bro
bro if you put me on an island with a
bunch of guys
who do you think's gonna rule the island
dude nah bro and that's what makes you
the you know what that makes you dude
you know what that makes you
you're not gonna be ashamed
of an island [ __ ] food you're not in
the car dude
there's soldiers and then there's the
guy who basically floats down you're
like you're like the leader in the waco
situation yeah
you're that guy do you think
i can't convince people
i can convince the [ __ ]
you know what you know what you know
he's actually right i mean think about
those idiots that have life tattoos
i just convinced you of this in 30
seconds
a second i knew it was happening where's
the kool-aid
when you look at people's eyes when i
talk bro people avert they go oh no dude
i'm [ __ ] i'm inside you dude you're
also not you know
you know what i do i'm not small dude
people think people see me and they go
oh i had no idea your shoulders went on
free we're the same size but dude we're
the same size okay well we're the exact
same time
but here's the thing i thought that for
years do you know what i do until like
two weeks ago i have a secret i have a
secret with that when i talk to you
and and and we're having a conversation
there he is there he is and i will tell
you right now those glasses
same guy i know and i'll tell you right
now i admire that guy okay sure but
when i talk to you and we're having a
conversation i imagine i imagine when
i'm talking to you i am imagining myself
crawling inside of you and wearing you
and that's how
i'm that guy
that's how i'm that guy so we're all on
an island the [ __ ] however many 20 30
people you know what i mean there's
always a limited amount if there's
[ __ ] you know thousands and thousands
of people
it'll be tough or if like rogan is there
yeah yeah
okay no but yeah but when the [ __ ] okay
but you talk about like tough and
fighting and [ __ ] yeah dude fine there's
people who are going to beat me up but
your boy's got the gift of gab dude and
and and when i'm imagining talk when i'm
talking to am i imagining wearing you
you don't know what to do you don't know
what to do you know what you got
bar fight you taking brian
i love chris but it was an actual fight
and my life was at stake i'd probably
take because i've actually had you know
i rest arrested brian i've felt his
strengths i've never wrestled you yeah i
don't know i'm wrestling but still like
you can tell their strength i i can kind
of tell their strength from nothing
stuff like that yeah because i'd have to
pick brian but
i'll tell you right now i'll tell you
right now if i wrestle brian i would win
a hundred percent we should do that next
i know we gotta that's okay yeah i
should do that next that's on the books
i'd love to see okay
yeah okay
he wouldn't de-escalate he'd make it no
yeah he would yeah but i mean if we're
going to actually get into a physical
fight that's what we're saying right who
would you want to win if i had to box
with brian then yeah i don't know that's
what he's been doing
in a bar fight setting isn't as
applicable as being able to strike yeah
so maybe in that setting specifically i
pick brian
i think you'd definitely win wrestling
yeah yeah yeah yeah no doubt we could
take one person for sure but then their
friends would be like oh [ __ ] you need
to strike right yeah but but what do you
think brian's going to be like [ __ ]
like fighting people knocking them out
and [ __ ] he's been in thousands of
suicides
he's not [ __ ] chowing on fat he's
just going to be [ __ ]
that's tough i'd take chris though
because brian's gonna escalate it oh
this guy's doing well so this is a cats
in the wild someone sent in it shows how
chris uh gets picks out his outfits
to montreal today get ready with me to
go to the
store long johns won't cut it today so
i'm going to do two pants oh my god
t-shirt magical girl sweater and a roll
up my
clothes she looks insane dude my whole
thing is it looks like chris if he died
yeah and he's got the face tattoo i'm
headed there but look
here's the thing here's the thing dude
why do you have to wear all this [ __ ]
yeah that's the it's like just even if
like first of all those pants it's too
much don't wear the cat shirt also in
the necklace
or like don't quilt don't wear the pants
and the shoes the boots the scarf i
guess is he in like toronto or like
montreal or she's just bitter [ __ ]
cold
oh it'd be great if he was in l.a and
just it's
april and he's just like so hot
remember when martin lawrence passed the
[ __ ] out because you like put on too
many layers remember that yeah don't be
doing that man i don't know if it was
the layers you fall down yeah
someone sent in uh me practicing
something
he's like he looks like you it's perfect
that's you did
i post this on my story and a number
number of people were like you're a
black belt
that guy gets some air huh my sister
asked me if he's
gnarly so i choose me in a bar fight
hell yeah that flying [ __ ] and then
we got one more cats in the wild someone
saw eric um
greatest hits they don't look like them
but they're really funny that little
twinkle me the starbucks the starbucks
oh my god
this one actually a fan filmed he saw
eric on the street okay
same wardrobe
so it's nice go ahead
so he looks great
don't tell me this don't look like aaron
griffin right here
wow looks just like boy
well from this distance maybe
i mean that guy is like five foot five i
don't know yeah small i think i think
it's the the tommy bahama team can you
bring it up
oh that's okay a little bit
a little bit exactly if eric was messy
if eric was an npc yeah yeah yeah that's
bakersfield griffin horrible hoodie
that shirt's better than the hoodie
thank you yeah
all right uh we've got a couple of my
hero got me this [ __ ] yeah it's cute we
got a couple kingdoms before we uh do
the cats dating game which we are now
rebranding to chinder because we have
the awesome thing very cool i will say
that that sounds racist but it's not we
shouldn't it started off as shinder and
then start off this channel i did create
that tinder sounds racist yeah
is this an imagination
my
yeah but some asian out there will be
like you know they do that all the time
yeah yeah okay true
and the girl we got this weekend
this guy saw chappelle's video and tried
to be sexy like him yeah more than one
column oh bro
open that window push him out dude too
many feet
look at the [ __ ] one with the body
get out of here no too many flavors
one for the winner did he steal all
these the way you end with my like ass
and gloom but bro that's [ __ ]
honestly that's 18 grand right there on
this one this guy's about to get fired
from macy's i'm going to say is that a
neiman marcus like you know that little
counter yeah that's a fire hazard right
there and that that is
what's the question he said king and are
stinging at more than one cologne
you want one set man so when people
smell you're like that's bishop no no no
no no dude what the [ __ ] are you saying
i like how outraged he is
when somebody walks into a room and you
just [ __ ] and they're all inside yeah
yeah yeah bro you just talking about
being inside you know
in my mind
oh you smell better looking then you're
not tricking anyone well no that guy's
spraying that [ __ ] because he probably
farted or he's covering marijuana i'm
just talking about little sprays what
you're saying
okay but how do you how do you put on
cologne where do you put it i put on my
neck and then i go under the shirt bro
how about how that's a lie though i want
to pick up the pheromones man i want to
smell the real brendan shop i want to
smell the real oh you want that you want
this sweet bones dude dude
sweet nectar but yeah how much sweet
nectar
no is understand but if you're with like
a chick and she's smelling like a
department store and you're like oh nice
and then the department store wears off
and you [ __ ] smell a little bit of
sandwich on her that's gross as [ __ ] man
you don't want sandwich smelling girl
smelling like a department store
tricking the [ __ ] out of you i'm not the
real [ __ ] because that's how it's gonna
last bro it's a lie man unless they
sting it's a lie but here's the other
thing though dude
women like what men they don't like a
[ __ ] guy smelling like aqua giorgio
what's the fahrenheit disagreement no no
because well that's what makes you wrong
somebody has to be wrong here dude but
what i'm telling you is
what i'm telling you is you don't wear
it let's get down let's boil it down to
the brass tacks dude
there is no cologne there is only
perfume so if you're a man and you get
cologne and you squirt it on you yeah
congratulations you're a woman
and that's okay it's 2022. you don't
wear anything where's your [ __ ] brendon
yeah daddy
i like that you own it but don't do that
man
just like on the island i think he
swayed eric exactly bro this is an
island boy no i was already on this on
this train this is highlighted
i i sometimes because i have like a but
my thing is just like did i take a
little dab
by the way about mayonnaise you talk
about mayonnaise
but i don't put it underneath i just put
it on your clothes
bro and what you're hot now
because when i'm doing the meet and
greets and somebody goes oh you smell
good yeah
give it to me
i'm with them man it's not to bring them
in it's to keep them close
dang you smell good and i have no idea
what it is yeah it's a silver bottle wow
it looks insane but i don't like too
much i i i i don't know i don't smell
like an armenian yeah you know what i'm
saying i don't want to i want to be
drenched in armenians like that's not
enough bro you need more squirts bro you
don't put it in your mouth like that
okay i don't know what accent that is
that's armenian bro did you go down to
glendale man that squirted in their
mouth man
[ __ ] you [ __ ] oh you like you
think oh my god that's where armenians
were when you grew up in la canada all
right there was no mexicans or armenians
let me know if i can shut up
armenian central bro it's armin et
cetera in la canada okay hey bro
i love the movie scarface that's what
they would all say all the time
[Laughter]
it's a latin reference yeah but that's
what they because well bro i mean we're
gonna get really racist in a second but
all i'm saying is armenians love the
movie scarface
first you get the man money then you get
the power then comes the respect no the
[ __ ] but that's what
dude
just [ __ ] colonist perfume
hit it there
yo what up cats crew uh brandon and
whoever else is there
it's your boy israel coming from uh two
from south texas i had a question for
y'all israel from eyebrows yeah we're
gonna discuss these eyebrows so
wow a couple months ago i proposed to
know my girlfriend of going on five
years next month nice and of course i
got her rigging stuff turn the music
down though you know i was wondering
what y'all think about men engagement
rings you know because typically the guy
waits until the wedding to get his so
i was actually wanting mine before and
she obviously threw it off at first i
was like no i'm serious i want it so
hopefully
she's going to
get me one now
that was kind of not the thing to do but
you know what
like march 2023 so i'm hoping that
she agrees with it i just want to get
those tape all right dudes dude don't
say deuce but also
but i love your eyebrows don't deuce it
didn't you you know what he panicked and
you know how to end the video and that's
fine i've been there the only thing is
is fair enough with the wedding stuff do
whatever the [ __ ] you want man yeah and
also get this big wedding small wedding
no perfume
yeah yeah i do but um
wait a minute hold on uh uh he's talking
he wants his own male engagement ring
it's just a man ring man it's like it's
usually that thick but i understand but
like but so so it's not the fact that he
wants jewelry because he could just get
a ring that's he could just mob it up
and put it on your pinky like you can do
that
yes you can start telling people what to
do
right
but here's what this guy's not talking
about here's my thing with rings though
you guys wear rings no
no no no you're going to wear one yeah
you're going to i will yeah i'm going to
[ __ ] are you going to do you put no i i
don't do are you chris angel
no are you are you do you know magic no
you can't wear rings okay listen just
like i really like what you're saying i
can't wear cologne you can't wear
jewelry
angel i'm a little bit you kiss age
okay you're not the guy on the island
that's on top and telling people what to
do and i am and it's making it an island
now but it's making you a little bit
upset because i kind of a little bit
understand where you're coming from
and i don't like that okay
i don't like that at all all right
he's inside you right now
i got the tattoo i don't i don't do it
crawling in my mouth is
that's fine but um no i i don't like
rings i don't like rings because if
because you want to wear you got to pick
you want rings you want chains you can't
wear both no i understand chris angel no
i i understand that i do understand that
i have bracelet on too no well no it's a
all right but i thought about it but i
thought about yes you're right
chain and ring is not going to pick
people you kind of have to pick i agree
with that um because we haven't really
talked about it you bad bunny i know i
know i'm not bad bunny but but like i i
and i understand i see here's the other
thing too i could go nuts oh and just
get all sorts of rings and jewelry and
then just be that guy yeah but you'd
also wear a cape that's right that's how
you look when you wear a wedding ring
yeah and also you've got to wear it he's
wearing cats
that's what you look like he's also got
the [ __ ] talk to your manager haircut
that's just hilarious his picture
um what's the cat like yeah yeah the
dad's like why am i into this um so
hold on that's gonna be me when i get my
guess
i'm gonna do that exact picture and
start wearing rings absolutely not just
for the picture though i i you know i
think i yeah like a watch with the ring
would look too much to me like my
brother wears that you know the the
sleep one the you know this yeah
yeah yeah if you don't know magic we
gotta take one off you gotta pick
i understand i i don't know i i kind of
want i wanna wear a [ __ ] wedding ring
but but then yes i gotta get rid of the
rolex i know bro i know no
i don't know man and i really like this
too gotta get really nice it's dainty
you know what i mean i'm not mad at it
yeah but you also have you have a couple
of dooky ones too though i do have a
dookie one yeah um what oh the cuban
link one yeah i had one i wore it the
other night on yeah yeah
yeah you've also got like
a a whole pendant with a kid or
something like that right
yeah but but again though you also have
a bunch of tattoos and stuff so it's
like that's like jewel that's skin
jewelry i don't know magic though
you know it's very either way listen to
my podcast congratulations
i forgot to say that let's take another
small little break we got to pay the
bills we got to pay the bills and listen
here man
you need sleep but you can't just sleep
on any old mattress we talking about my
friends at helix sleep listen to this
helix sleep they got a little quiz takes
just two minutes to complete it matches
your thick ass body type all right with
the perfect mattress built for you all
right you like the mattress soft firm
you sleep on your side your back your
stomach you sleep hot you sleep cool
with helic we got a mattress made just
for you man helix sleep was awarded the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2019 and 2020 by gq and wired magazine
all i have is helix sleep in my crib i
can't get my friends out of the house i
can't get my father-in-law out of the
house because they love the beds just go
to helixsleep.com kats take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they will
match you with the perfect mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life
maybe maybe your podcast head maybe
you're a gamer and you don't got time to
make food you don't got time to make
lunch or breakfast or dinner you're like
what am i going to do
i i don't want to cook we got you man
because you're working up an appetite
yeah you know who got you covered
grubhub they got you covered grubhub got
you covered all right and this show is
sponsored by grubhub and they have all
the stuff you need from go-to items
every day late night snacks paper towels
soda whatever you need food dinner lunch
breakfast we got it with you all right
grubhub got you covered order your
convenience items through grubhub app or
online grubhub is the way to go get
whatever you want delivered right to
your door just in the nick of time you
never even have to leave the crib order
your convenience items through the
grubhub app or online and it's time for
gender
[Music]
[Applause]
can you play this and it's okay
that's our song it's our song that's gin
singing it'll probably get played
this is hilarious why did where was he
last time when we were [ __ ] killing
it eric and i he shot when i had to
destroy
i look kind of good i look good i see
myself i look good
you're white huh you know what it is i'm
white but you know what more is i'm
almost gray that's yeah you're walking
dead color i'm [ __ ] on the way to
zombie i'm just got bitten guy yes
did you we need to hold on stay away
from him that's me give him a few days
sure do we know this young lady has she
been on before i like how chin thinks
he's in a boy band you could tell by the
way he was singing that he thought he
was in like well no you thought he was
an asian instinct i mean
the gang yeah okay it would have to be
and then and then chill didn't you go on
like go for it was it america's got
talent or something oh no the other one
you're not what gang you're gonna be in
you can't go from my mouth imagine
imagine there's no money
hey hey
[Laughter]
do we have footage no thank god because
i messed up [ __ ] up yeah no
by being on it yeah way too cocky i
drank the night before i was going crazy
oh really there's no footage you
sabotage it's gotta be out there you
sabotage yourself luckily it never
lasted the show
is that why you did nevertheless yeah
the students saw the red light going
they're like red light means everyone's
watching i'm like
oh i forgot my lyrics i messed it up oh
my god
let's get a reminder of who shelby was
okay oh that's a you know what dude
recaps are great
was she on the last one with when i was
on yeah yeah we saw oh there's her okay
okay it was the friend so this is
actually a girl i i i remember yeah
right right yeah yeah yeah her friend
was dope too but oh that's right
she's married yeah that's her
she has the wrist like you yeah it's
probably the real person is probably the
first girl and that's why she can't get
on video and she's just like sure
there's a picture of another girl
you need to let me in
you hear a knock and nick letter yeah
that'll win
oh there you go
oh we got you girl
hi how you doing what up after all that
you just say hi
this meeting is being recorded
oh [ __ ] they just exposed us
how are you doing why you put that
picture up next to this like just a
reminder like
it was up she's trying to be like she's
not just making it big so we can talk to
her
right
but we're going to bring up the video i
got it okay perfect
uh but yeah what what's going on shelby
not a whole lot um
just chilling you're well you just
what time is it there you so you you're
two hours ahead do you work
did you take time off of work to do this
or
uh tuesdays are actually my day off so
it worked out perfect
now before we get into these uh handsome
submissions what's the dating life been
in austin for you
um i don't really date in austin i don't
like the date being full that's here
why why
you tried how you tried how you're
talking tinder yeah
what did you try bumble grinder
dating apps just aren't it for me um i
like meeting people really like in
person
something like this is out of my
comfort zone
yep a lot of fun um but yeah i mean
i've been here for five years i
originally came from dallas so i've been
here for five and a half years and in
that time i just haven't really had a
lot of success with because
she doesn't like all the guys that's
what she's saying yeah so where do you
have where do you hang out that you to
meet guys what do you like to do bars
clubs what do you do yeah i mean bars
and clubs sometimes but i know that's
not necessarily the best place to meet a
guy smart girl but
i've met some people here and there
either at work or just
through work i uh work in the service
industry so
um as a server i meet a lot of people
but
okay well maybe we can help you out do
people ever leave you their numbers on
receipts and stuff for you
that happens quite often yeah yeah of
course yeah do you ever follow up never
oh have you ever followed up okay who
are you looking back at tell that person
to come say shelby i think yeah who's
that person just tell them to come say
hi cause we sick of you looking over
there
so bring bring this person over just say
hi what if it was calling calen
[Laughter]
all right uh
wait hold on have you ever do you ever
follow up you ever follow up with the
guys that leave you their number or no
you don't do that
um not usually but you have okay if he's
like wearing a suit or something
yeah if they really sparked something
then yeah maybe but
i'm less likely to
reach out over text okay cool
all right cool we'll watch some of these
guys she can only she's picking only on
what they how they describe themselves
she can't see she can't see it yeah she
has to pick three guys but just based on
their personality
man she can she'll see him when we talk
to him but yeah okay it's like that dang
game we're gonna pick we're going to
help her narrow down okay okay okay i'm
not going to be [ __ ] shitty about
this i'm going to you're going to get
the right guy dude
no we don't [ __ ] around
dude we had a couple get married from
this segment get the [ __ ] out bro
they're going to get the worst
who's over there woman who's over there
is it so dude are you married yeah wow
amazing nothing that's his kink he's
like a guy yeah all right all right
here's the first guy it's just some
what's up king in the sting this is nate
coming at you from austin texas saw the
episode about shelby um i would love to
submit my name to be on that calabasas
love companion i'm 25 i'm 510 i'm a
supervisor for a construction company
here in the city
i live by myself in my own apartment um
she looks like she's fit like she's into
doing stuff outside
not just going to sixth street and doing
cocaine drinking white claws
um so let me know i know i'm not the
typical uh staple of beauty you know i
got my head shaved i got a weird [ __ ]
mustache i got tattoos and stuff
um but let me know let me know i think
i'd uh be good for the show love to meet
her she's super cute um let me know gang
gang buzz buzz okay so i like this guy i
like to do a background check i don't
know
it seems like it seems like a good
business seems like a good sure
background
always background checks feels like it
seems like a good guy
uh there's two things i don't like about
him number one uh he he's got uh
more face hair than hair hair i that's
the thing that i just don't go on the
bottom i'm not i don't do that turn your
[ __ ] head upside down and get it
right he's got zero lips number two
number two uh he's doing it from the
inside of a jail cell so i don't know if
you want no um no he's he's a he seems
like a nice guy he seems like a nice guy
and not a bad start yeah
he's up front
yeah he was yeah
i'll give him that yeah he was up front
yeah uh so shelby make sure you're
marking down which one which guys you
like that was nate
okay
this next guy has to draw like quagmire
or jay leno so this guy he's he's not a
bad looking guy but i can already tell
this guy's a problem
cat squad what is good theo brennan
stevie dude from workaholics appreciate
you all calling in
shelby that's true what about me i'm
brian 28 years old um in la moved out
here about a year ago from new york um
for work i work at tick tock and
for activities i like to like stay in
shape work out basketball running
boxing lifting weights
snowboarding surfing things like that
i get a dog my own right now he's all
jump roping six one two hundred and
eight
five pounds 36 inch waist 32 inch inseam
okay um shelby looks like a qd i've
called him before about my dating and
romance situations that's over now so
back in the game um yeah hit me up i
like this guy
he seems like a solid guy
except a long distance that's a minus
yeah la austin it's not a terrible
flight but not ideal what else we got
okay my name is brandon i'm 31. i hate
the name in west virginia but um
bigger city-wise i'm closer to
pittsburgh pennsylvania than anywhere
way too much i am 6'1 220 pounds
you can do the math there it's not
fantastic but it's not bad and uh
funny let's see i'm a union electrician
apprentice i have a year left of trade
school where i'll get my degree and take
it to basically go
anywhere and work as an electrician good
hands good with that on my fallback
because i plan on becoming a fly fishing
guide and moving out of here anyway and
i can make a lot of money open the
suggestions on where to move
let's see i am a us army veteran of four
years oh wow i've been out since 2014
longest relationship was four years
and i've been single a little over a
year small town dating scene
not being the best
so let me know if you guys can uh find
me something
i like him i think he's the sweetest guy
he's actually i think he's also the
hardest worker the only thing is he he
lives far but he did say once he gets
his uh oh okay nope
nope but no
but no
no but i got confused with this guy
is in the back of an uber doing this
dude what the [ __ ] is that m night
shyamalan what are you trying to do dude
chin left before the [ __ ] thing even
came up
this nice guy looks insane wow his face
right maybe his face changes when he
talks a little bit no it's not good it's
not a good beginning video yeah his jaws
let's destroy this let's play this his
jaw is so strong he looks like he never
laughs he just looks like he never i
think it's because his cheekbones
he's a wax but it could be it could be
you know this could be he could be
awesome it could be good he could be
awesome
hey what up king of the sting okay i'm
not expecting that
from san francisco where the hippies
stay trippy okay main reason i'm making
this video actually is because i'm gonna
share your insta post about yourself
i would love to throw my hat in the ring
uh main reason why shelby should
consider me is because i'm kind
compassionate
uh relatively humble when am i bragging
on a video is this bottom lip i like
this guy and
hot
i also love working out like five days a
week
being outdoors with nature
uh occasional hunting actually
uh and i'm actually a really big fan of
austin as well i've been there a couple
times
saw austin city limits for the first
time last year had a blast with my
friends
um and yeah you know we're both seconds
it's a lot he's definitely the best
looking yeah he he's the weirdest and
best looking that makes sense
he's made out of mouth but
we have to ask shelby like so shelby are
you open to
you know all races non-white guys like
all right whatever are you open to
whatever this guy is yeah yeah and we're
not saying he's black she is yeah why
would you have to say that well i'm just
i don't know like
because we need to assume you know like
we're talking all races i honestly don't
know if he's black or not yeah oh i do
okay well don't spoil shelby have you
dated a black guy before
yeah it's okay good all right we're good
she's in she's have you dated an indian
man
no no of course no she has not look at
her no bro of course not look at her you
can't even no i mean come on you know
and she's sure she's taking notes and
she sure as [ __ ] doesn't date a guy like
this either nick you know
yeah yeah she's definitely not dating a
guy like this white either yeah so this
guy's this guy's too white for me yeah
yeah this is matt from austin and he
clearly works at dick's sporting goods
yeah
king and staying squad eric theo brandon
i mean
this one the other recently canceled
comic who's trying to make a comeback
what's happening
uh
love you guys but this video is for my
girl shelby well stop moving the camera
my name's matt i'm a 27 year old veteran
i just got out of the military jesus is
great you're a fan base bro new life
you like your freedom i'd love to enjoy
them with you
not from this guy's ride with some cheap
beer on the
dash always
throw down the blanket and uh have a
charcuterie board under a nice sunset
choice is yourselves the choices shelves
giving nicknames already you like
chiseled jawlines
you know what i'm saying and uh in a
soft touch i might be your guy oh wow i
mean
he's got a sense of humor yeah i like
them but that creeped me out he's not
you know the problem is you the the
world the equilibrium is off there
because she's a bona fide hottie he you
know he's out he's taking his coverage
there yeah yeah yeah he's he's got a
sense of humor though and yeah he's a
he's a
veteran yeah he's in austin i feel like
if he cleaned up he could be okay i like
that we can't change anybody though okay
no but i feel like you're gonna you know
oh dude here's another one
can i just say this guy these people
have seen how shelby looks yeah all
right yeah present yourself in a way
that you're like kind of yeah look good
with you yeah you know what i mean true
good
[ __ ] are coming in like you
know looking like a five and we trying
to but and then they're also like in
their gym clothes it's like come on man
you know her dm's are filled with dicks
it's jelly yeah she can't even all the
notifications that are coming in is like
yeah right
you know come on man
this guy um is uh
we were making fun of the other guy with
the pause this is a worse pause
this guy looks like he's trying to sell
many scripts right now it's not working
but that's yeah but that's bad
is it but he look he's trying to pop bro
all right we got two more we'll get it
in this guy okay
he got a chin situation how's it going
uh my name is justin i'm 31 years old
he's the nicest guy we have las vegas
um i'm a personal trainer nutritionist
nice business owner
um and as cheesy as it sounds i'm
looking for love right i think we all
are right am i right to spit myself
and see if there's any sparks that can
fly on this show um and hopefully shelby
and i connect
and can kind of go from there so
i'm hoping you guys give me an
opportunity to be on this week's show
he's a nice guy i'm really excited big
fan i watch all the episodes i like this
game so i can't wait to hear from you
guys hopefully i get a call soon all
right thank you yeah
he's not so
out of kicking his coverage yeah yeah
yeah i know i like his personality yeah
i like how he was like he no
expectations let's see what happens one
thing though what is it
he's not sexy yeah well he's not sexy
he's handsome he's good looking the
sexist has been the guy that looks like
milk chocolate yeah he's a sexy guy that
guy's a sexy guy but he knows that she's
kissing but he knows it though so we
don't know if shelby he likes the guy
who knows it or if he likes the guy
who's like i don't get hey you know what
show you like you know what shelby likes
i'll tell you right now what she'll be
like what a show you don't know she'll
be like i do know okay shelby likes a
guy that that thinks maybe he's sexy but
also like doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like
why would i give a [ __ ] about being sexy
that's what [ __ ] shelby likes am i
right shelby
you're right bingo
and and who was that the first guy
now i don't know if she would like the
way the first guy looks because he has
upside down head right
yeah
and what and there was no lip right
right and what he's lacking in his upper
lip what he's lacking in his upper lip
he makes up no no there was nobody
here's bryant gumbel right right
so so so i don't know if she was like a
puppet
because it needs everything but what i
know for sure is she's not gonna like
this guy we're about to look at
i agree are you talking peter my
videographer chin
come on this guy come on this guy's
clean let's see this guy oh yeah oh yeah
cause that's the number one thing girl
who do you like okay clean clean yeah
they're better all these shelby's
apartment it's clean it is clean yeah
put together okay hit it nick but i'm
with chris on this hi guys my my name's
david okay i'm 30 years old
guy [ __ ] love spider-man uh stop
trader as well as uh guy goes no way
home
um exactly full time
you asked
once or twice a month for work at least
and
i watch the show her best friend watches
the show so i'm sure we have a similar
sensibility sense of humor she's nice i
love to go out
you know dress up nice go out have a
good time totally yeah it's kind of i
like to look like she likes didn't dress
up
and yeah not today though
yeah
no no this guy this guy's this guy's the
bomb dress out this guy's nice this
guy's nice
that that guy's nice
i don't know if it's a fit for sure i
don't know if it's a fit but he's a good
guy yeah these are all good choices you
know the last three were like more that
their personalities were nicer than like
you know what i mean yeah all right
shelby uh which three would you like to
talk to oh man i
okay um
i'm gonna go with mj
brian and justin
mj is uh mj brian
yeah the guy in the back of the uber
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she might like
him mm-hmm maybe she might
because he hit that tone in his voice
like girl
he also said that i'm also sexy so
there's that yeah when you say that you
just outright be like and i'm hot he did
say hi yeah he said he said he was hot
oh this guy
yeah yeah
you know what i like bro is the [ __ ]
the guy had the earpiece in i really
like that man i like the air traffic
control i like this jacket bro i'm
bro i'm gonna date these dudes
and
shelby if you don't already uh put it on
gallery view and you'll be able to see
all four of them yeah you get to see all
of them
this really looks like a 90s boy band
you know what i mean bro the guy with
the nirvana shirt on looks like he would
be a guy to make a documentary about
that was a serial killer for sure 100
no doubt dude no yeah i mean it'd be
like we didn't we didn't really have any
idea we didn't know yeah you know
[ __ ] and [ __ ] looks like don't [ __ ] with
cats yeah yeah yeah
don't [ __ ] with dogs
you need stuff on your walls and your
zoom background it creeps people out
when you're in them yeah bro
now shelby you can see them right yeah
uh yeah oh i can see two of them and
then one's on another page but okay how
can we ask you something who do you
think's who
of what you when you have your notes
well she knows who the [ __ ] one is
well their names are beloved oh never
mind then okay
well let's do this let's do this let's
make love happen uh so shelby and you
guys can ask these gentlemen questions
and then she'll eliminate one we'll
narrow it down to two and then she'll
pick one from there shall we do do you
want to take it away you want us to
start this off how how do you want to do
it it's your love life she looks like a
i take charge type of character nah nah
what do you want to do she don't don't
what do you feel like
um
y'all can kind of help me out a little
bit yeah i knew she was gonna say that
bro i'm good man yeah don't stand up
though you know
although i thought
you know do that island thing yeah i
know i do i can't bro i'm an island but
i'm the island boy well all right
uh who we starting with you want to
start with
let's start with the [ __ ] hoodie dude
the guy who you know basically curly top
yeah
no they're back if you say they're back
they're back
bro let me tell you something right now
come on let me tell you right now
let me tell you right now if you're
gonna [ __ ] don't be asking if
mustaches are back you tell shelby
mustache is your [ __ ] back dude
and this is what shelby this is what
shelby responds to agree hey brian what
what was the last relationship you were
in and why did it end
yeah you guys actually know about it i
called it about it oh yeah i forget
though you know
yeah no you guys get a lot of calls i
don't know i was dating this girl out
here in l.a it was going really well but
then like her ex was still super in the
picture and just like a little too much
you could handle i remember you to a
wedding with you oh you know what she
flew to the wedding
yeah yeah oh my dude [ __ ] that you
needed to get rid of her what were you
even doing in that relationship i had to
move on brother so oh my god we broke up
and then um
yeah yeah i've just kind of been ever
single ever since so i guess we kind of
broke up there's just too much
involvement with the x she was a great
girl um super pretty super nice athletic
it was all good but but she said it was
a little too confusing for me so we
parted ways it's nice how he's it's nice
how he's like not bad-mouthing her yeah
i know because i wouldn't want harder to
paint on her ass yeah we went hard in
the paint i would have went way harder
than he did uh
i'm good brother what was your last
relationship man you seem a little bit
like a player not gonna lie you're a
handsome dude i was about to say you got
the fur around the neck
very confident how how can we talk about
the denim you know trying to appease
that texas nature
what was the last relationship you're in
that's a that's a great question so last
relationship i was in was about an
eight-year relationship wow i started
when i was 17 did there for a minute
pandemic hit you know kind of realized i
wanted to like go around a little bit
broke things off with her um yeah and
i'm ready to get back into the game wow
do you do you go out a lot do you do you
date a lot are you on the dating apps
yeah i i do pretty good yeah i'm on
tinder bumble
um all of the above yeah a quick quick
question though so you were in a
eight-year relationship yeah pandemic
hit and then you decided
you need to get out more yeah that's a
crazy
i was just stuck in that house for so
long you know just those four walls just
had to get out there i'm with him though
when you're locked down yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you learn about it
yeah
all right well i like this guy door open
everything yeah it was too much wow okay
and how is the dating scene been going
up there in san fran
not too bad yeah i mean not like two
bone horn or anything but you're pretty
good yeah you're slinging yourself i
think you like to toot your own horn
it's okay yeah a little
justin what's going on doug
what's up guys how's it going what's up
man how's vegas life
vegas is good yeah and just shelby fyi
i'm not a serial killer
that's what they say though that's what
serial killers say that's something
serial killer would say
vegas vegas life is cool actually moved
from la during the pandemic to be out
here close to family oh that's nice yeah
hashtag good guy um that's a good guy
how's the dating life in vegas going a
lot of [ __ ] out there
yeah it's uh it's tough man it's it's
filled with like industry girls and
strippers so it's it's really hard to
find like you know quote-unquote wifey
right it's also awesome though at the
same time
it's all good yeah put a little bit of
investment in there
shelby any questions
yeah i've got a few um i guess we'll
go in that same rotation so you start
with bro oh nice um
you listed a lot of hobbies i remember
you went down the list yeah he listed
every athletic activity yeah
he's even a cheerleader
sorry what was the question
what's more of your day-to-day hobbies
like something that
you do every day
um
yeah i mean uh hobby-wise i didn't work
out i try and do some type of workout i
might just get my
steps in and walk around the
neighborhood um lift weights
surge or something like that i mean my
day to day is just like wake up work on
my day job got some hot side hustles
work on those
might hop on some video games with the
boys for a little bit at the end of the
day i moved out to l.a pretty recently
i'm from new york and so that's a good
way to catch up with friends i'll play
some some halo or something with them so
yeah just work eat work out pretty basic
no pretense i like that yeah yeah all
right
mj
how's it going show me
today it's [ __ ] guy bro you got an r
b i'm coming out
don't worry
what's up my girl what's up my girl
what's up cute genuine right now please
why are my pants off all right go mj
okay sorry um same question what's more
of your day-to-day hobbies something
that you practice every day working out
well i'm definitely like working out
going out in nature like i was saying my
video um yeah just chilling just going
with the flow really depends like who
i'm hanging out with like the vibe in
general the vibe so many things
if i'm being honest
yeah i think it's too much pressure to
do that okay
i like that i i'm the same way bro well
i'm pretty strict scared now you got a
kid your day is planned out no but we
chilled do we don't [ __ ] go do [ __ ]
we're just kidding
yeah the kid chills he does what daddy
does yeah yeah
now justin
justin
uh you said that you're a personal
trainer is that something that you're
doing every day or you work with clients
or how does that go yeah yeah so aside
from like trying to get myself in shape
i i help a lot of people i'm a
nutritionist and trainer so that's kind
of my day-to-day is working with upwards
of like 20 clients a day okay um and
then i also help um i consult for
fitness studios around like the us so i
help like uh fitness studios kind of
help um with their sales growth so
uh it's it's a pretty busy day and then
when i have time i like to walk my dog
and go hiking out here um red rock
canyon so i try to stay out of the house
as much as possible um when i'm working
i love if we were doing [ __ ] marry kill
we're marrying him
yeah i'll probably [ __ ] mj am i right
yeah we're [ __ ] mj i'm so [ __ ]
sorry ryan
sorry
all right shelby i get rid of one
oh [ __ ]
a word who's this now that's just that's
the personal trainer that's justin oh
you try okay first of all open with this
just
nah that's why it's good it's good that
he didn't open with that like that's not
that's not what's important
this is like he's bruce banner on the
screen yeah
shelby can't see this justin you pulled
up your after picture on your latest
instagram post yeah and also get some
shorts
no they did fit before you started
working out yeah yeah
justin that's your body currently
uh it's actually a little bit better but
yeah i had a oh
oh you did have a big transformation
you know you look good sick too though
man you're a man you know what i mean
like belly button's big enough to do you
know what i mean sorry i feel like i'm
swaying i'm hurting no no no
no no no no no everyone every these
three guys are all they're you're all
good
by the way yes this is actually the best
set i've seen yeah you know what i mean
i'm not worried about any of these guys
killing you shelby yeah these guys are
good these guys are all good choices
but you gotta you gotta eliminate one
shelbs all right this is hard i'm not a
heartbreaker i'm sorry
oh you're a heartbreaker shut the [ __ ]
up
it's not enough that's not up to you man
all you do is
[Laughter]
yeah um
okay i'm sorry justin um
i don't think
all good no worries sorry justin keep on
trucking yeah
sorry bro you're fine bro you're fine
bro fine dawg
all right
now we know more we've we've learned a
lot about shelby right yeah
[Laughter]
nice guys with a good career she's like
shelby are you in new york city
no but i'm wearing a new york i've never
been i gotta okay cool that's the front
that's where our first day is gonna be
it's perfect
okay god this guy is
just
dude
milk chocolate ass
that mj's
yeah man she got that stingray uh all
right
mj you're you're you you come to austin
what's the first thing you're gonna do
with shelby what's plan out the first
date i know you don't like the plan but
we're got to plan a little bit yeah sure
i mean like probably like a nice dinner
um get to know you a little better i'll
take around austin check out like the
nice city spots
um check out the music venue there see
what's up
yeah like what do you like doing in
austin specifically shelby
beautiful city i like i like being
outdoors and kind of getting
around um downtown and um
the lakes and everything he got her
flustered
we're all flustered
she's all like okay who i don't know
what i want to do
[ __ ] whatever you wherever you want to
go where you won't take me
baby that's the benefit of being dark no
one can see what i'm blushing it's
perfect
he said it before
dude mj is butter baby brian you got to
get some catching up to do brian
ah brian's comfortable brian's
comfortable bryce comes in yeah brian's
not shook
what what what would your date be brian
yeah i mean you know i want to get to
know shelby a little bit better
understand what she likes to do what our
interests are and then set up a date
around that but um i have family in
austin so i know the area pretty well
maybe grab some food walk around zilker
park my sister actually has like a juice
company down there i don't know if
you're into a healthy food chub we'd go
grab some food down there um yeah just
something maybe see some music a lot of
good live music out there
um you know something mellow somewhere
you can just talk a lot we don't want to
go like just watch a movie and sit and
feed her right and stare at the screen
together but that's stupid get to know
you learn about you hear about your life
experiences what you like what you don't
like um yeah it's something we could
just do together very interesting this
guy is just comfortable bro yeah
what kind of yeah you might trying too
hard any questions shelves before you
eliminate one of them
um
no i think i kind of know okay what is
your friend that's sitting right there
yeah that's what we want to know
why they being shy i don't get it who's
over there why they being shy
i don't know they're being goofy oh
there's more than one
well she but she she she knows who she
wants go ahead chelsea oh she's all
she's known from the beginning i feel
like that's a guy back there i feel like
he's a king and a sting fan he's like no
it's a girl it's girls there's a couple
of her girlfriends or one or maybe her
gay friend you know what i mean
you know he's like get the dark one baby
would you say shelves do i get to choose
now yeah you're up girl
um
mj i'm sorry i don't think your
attitude's a fit for me
oh you
i didn't see this guy
but i think brian's brian's the one no
you keep doing you mj bro you got no
prize guys got no [ __ ] problems yeah
he's not worried he's hungry he's on
tinder right now
on the screen did you see those two
those two doors behind him they both
have girls in them
mj has seven dates tonight yeah whatever
all right [ __ ] it
mj keep killing it dude proud of you as
well thanks man all right brother you
handsome bastard bro we knew you come on
[ __ ] you knew this guy you
can't pick anybody but this guy he's so
comfortable look at him
but the way he [ __ ] talks and i was
just chilling and he never got shook by
mj
what he said about the [ __ ] date bro
yeah he recovered after the mj very nice
yeah
you know why you stayed yourself
he was he was yeah i'm just trying to be
real she seems like a great girl want to
get to know her wasn't trying to do too
much yeah just kind of seems like a
great guy but
um
we all assumed mj had an std well we say
that just we should really oh for sure
he's he's had a shot a couple of times
maybe we just reimburse him but i feel
like we should really try to connect
these two yeah yeah yeah these two i'm
down to do whatever you guys want to do
cool well we're gonna really try
yes i'm in austin okay what if you went
like this oh [ __ ] well we can't do this
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa i thought you
were i don't know my mom and two sisters
live there i'm there all the time boom
he's there all the time and your mom
would love for you to move home right
yeah probably are you planning on going
there anytime soon we'll set up a date
and take care of it
um yeah i'm actually gonna be there in
april um because
yeah both of my sisters are having
babies maybe tmi but anyways i have two
nephews and nieces do then so i'll be in
town for that yeah you need to go a
little sooner it goes too far okay we'll
be in touch works too we'll be in touch
yeah yeah we'll make it happen either
way you two you know what you got this
is a cute-ass couple yeah yeah yeah look
at them they look good
thanks for playing you too hopefully
there's something good for you
guys
young kids man
well shelves hopefully it works out if
you got any problems uh
let chris know call eric brian what do
you do for tick tock
um yeah i do like brand partnership so i
work with some of our like big
advertising accounts and help them do
their advertising can you help us gain
an algorithm or is that not yours
yeah let's talk man i i can help you
guys out a little bit yeah let's do it
all right brother good luck you love our
birds
we'll be in touch be good see ya
go bye
wow wow that was a good couple that was
a good one yeah what that's all we do i
feel like mj made that whole segment
yeah he's he's [ __ ] right now i don't
know i know mk was jacking off while
doing it yeah yeah i knew he was getting
bj
under the
oh yeah
i forgot now every time you get a bj
this song's gonna come in your head
you got any more dates chris
uh san diego it's sold out i might i
don't know i don't know yeah no but so
i'm uh we just announced today i'm in
atlanta february 3rd through the 5th i'm
coming to atlanta baby february third
through the fifth where tickets at
atlanta atlanta get that f-a-t-k-z
dot-com i'm just gonna be at the city
yeah
no i am atlanta i'm not oh here's
atlanta you might say magic city eating
wings looking at asses i don't know come
get your tickets f-a-t-k-z.com february
3rd through the 5th the whole thick
squad will be there then end of february
i'm in sacramento punch line that's the
end of february
mr griffin house of comedy this weekend
in edmonton so it's gonna be cold oh and
this squad will be at the hollywood
improv on the 26th of january wednesday
one night one night only shop and
friends these are my friends oh you're
gonna be there too couple other funny
friends i'll be around right 26 i should
be is that it yeah that's it and next
week we got this crew plus krista
stefano so monster show
where here yeah oh am i on it yeah okay
cool yeah i already confirmed yeah yeah
no i'm on fire okay no we got a cowbest
fight companion in this [ __ ]
saturday yeah thick boy only ufc 270
crystalia brian cowan myself tune in
love you guys theo miss ya we're out
king in the state
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan vo2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at
parkway now he only finished boys in the
hallway this ain't the greatest show on
earth and what you call that eric
griffin with them he the nate dogger
podcast
[Music]
griffin just walked in and got it lit
you can't forget about brennan he still
need everything dick dick they still got
the bees and the trap trapping
still the king and the sting so quit
asking
if you know then you know it's a cat's
thing ball and chain hair swang like the
rat king king and the stink back with
the crew we got stevie weeby eric
griffin brendan theo too yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you